joining us here is one of the all-time
greats in the history of the sport
hockey hall-of-famer the man who retired
is the highest-scoring left winger in
the history of the National Hockey
League a multiple Stanley Cup champion
Luc Robitaille the president of the Los
Angeles games good to see you sir how
are you doing well you want to answer
that poll question what are you tired of
most in terms of sequels it seemed like
there's a lot of sequels for Star Wars
but I don't follow the whole vague so
you didn't see solo this week I didn't
see so yeah okay but you saw last
night's game one correct so last what do
you think of that what does somebody
like yourself a big-time school like
yourself think of 10 goals in Game one
of us well the cup finally ten goals is
the amount of goals that we scored in
our first series both teams when we lost
against Vegas they scored seven we
scored three the entire series in the
first round so it was you know it was a
great game to watch it was a lot of fun
to watch was up and down and it was
every time it seemed like one team would
score the other team was was coming down
it was a lot of speed was it was good it
was a good show to watch in terms of
what you just pointed out though 10
goals in the first series between
franchise kings and the Vegas Golden
Knights in four games combined period
and we saw 10 last night is this is this
just the wear and tear of a long
grinding playoff hockey season you know
it just seemed like guys were finding
holes last night there were there were a
few mistakes yeah maybe nerves I mean
there were a few mistakes that those two
teams don't make you know and I don't
think it's gonna happen going forward
the first game you're all hyped up and
there was like I think five or six days
between between the des plaines so that
does make a difference but certainly
made it for an exciting game and when
you see a pregame extravaganza like
something that's like Wayne Wayne and
mr. Chow were the only Vegas luminaries
that seem to be listening yeah it was
long the players don't see this you know
but it certainly are there waiting down
the hallway and that's a long time to
wait
seem that guy was going on forever well
you saw it a couple times right we see a
couple times but it certainly it seemed
to suit that up since the first round
they seem to have added like another
four or five minutes to it I know and
they Michael buffers announcing like
it's a like it's a prizefight that did
look like a Star Wars sequel out there a
little bit right there
what are we seeing in the Vegas nights
what can you put her in perspective in
here look it's a you know no one
predicted that they would get they would
get here now everyone knew they had a
pretty good team I think they've they
played all year with a lot of speed you
got to give credit to George McPhee's
like he he knew what he wanted he wanted
speed he wanted these type of players
and then you got to give credit to their
coach II they haven't changed from Game
one they played the same way they always
seems to have a defenseman jumping up in
the play they play with a tremendous
amount of speed and they're not
surprising anyone anymore they're just
coming at you it's like non-stop and and
at the same time there's something to
say about like hey seemed like everyone
their players is playing a little bit
above what their expectations are like
you know a lot of guys were having good
careers in the NHL but everybody seems
to be playing to another level and I
think it has a lot to do they seem like
they're all in that zone you know you
call it the zone or they're they're not
playing for a statistic they're playing
for the team and they're really there
it's amazing though with their plane and
so do you think when it's all said and
done I guess as somebody who's played as
long as you did and now as the president
the Kings as you are Luc Robitaille that
general managers are kicking themselves
across the landscape right now for
letting some of these guys go I I'm not
sure they're kicking himself for letting
guys go I think I do think the next time
around it's gonna be different I think
teams like we kind of sat us as an
organization and we knew we can only
protect so many guys and then we were
like well whomever we lose will lose and
we're gonna have to adjust so we didn't
make any trades to make sure we didn't
lose a certain player I think in the
future I would be surprised that teams
are making as many trades to not lose a
certain player like
Florida made a couple moves and they may
end up giving much more to protect one
guy over the other versus and and you
still don't know which player Vegas
gonna pick when it gets down to the end
so you're playing like it's it's like
poker in a way and so George makes who
handled it perfectly he kept his his
cars really close to himself and he
ended up getting you know what no one's
talking about he but he put up a good
team this year but he racked up a whole
bunch of pics too so for the next 2-3
years he's got a lot of draft picks so
that's gonna help this franchise for the
future we had him on last week and he's
like anybody who's complaining about the
rules about how I made it I guess easier
yeah bring expansion a team that those
teams accepted this seventeen million
dollar check from his owner yeah no I
know every team I think but but you got
to remember it was the owners that voted
to make it more to make it that way I
mean Gary Bettman and Bill Daley and the
league kind of changed the format a
little bit and but the owners agreed to
it they said yeah we want a team to come
in and have some type of success we
don't want them to to to be in the
bottom you know twenty you know bottom
five or bottom ten the league for ten
years and that's what happened to a few
teams over the expansion that shouldn't
happen Luc Robitaille here on the Rich
Eisen show so Tom Wilson got three games
from breaking Aston Reese's jaw earlier
in these playoffs now he hits Marcia so
last night
the refs get together decided not to
give him a major penalty now this might
this is in the hands one would think of
the front office of the National Hockey
League do you think Tom Wilson should be
sent in these finals based on the Board
of Governors I gotta be careful what I
say but but I would say they're the way
the rule works or the way I think the
league looks at those hitters it's time
so from the time the guy gets rid of the
puck and then until he's open you know
they figure that out and then does he
hit the head I think you know if you
don't hit the head he it sounds like he
if he hasn't gotten a call today yet it
sounds like he he's gonna get away with
it but if you don't hit the head you
probably can get away with it but it's
definitely the time from the time the
guy the Putney's is sick as he was he
already coming that way to there's
there's different ways they're looking
at they really break it down the league
does a good job at jorge perroso it was
a part of in the head of the community
for suspension they break down the play
I mean they see literally you know we're
not seeing all the camera angles are
seen so they're they're probably you
know looking at was he lining up to hit
him was a player aware that he was
coming and then looking and he count the
time from the time the puck leaves are
sick well in in the National Football
League there's something called a
defenseless player they're hitting
somebody who's defenseless yeah and it
certainly looked like March or so was
defenseless now that said it is the
Stanley Cup Finals you should have your
head on a swivel to is another way to
take a look at it but he was definitely
not again he wasn't contacted in the
head yeah but when you're hit that way
and defenseless there's the ice that
will definitely contact you in the head
he knew it was coming I would agree with
that they it's definitely it's a hard
one it's a but I know the guys they're
like they're not favoring one player
over the other they know Tom Wilson's
been caught a few times so you know so
they're looking at everything and you
know but let me let me take you out of
your role as executive executive I don't
want you to get a phone call from Batman
although if you do during this
conversation will you let me say yeah I
promise
so the thing I want to say though is
would you as an old-school player
somebody who's played there who's been
there and done that want to see a rule
that there's a defenseless player in
hockey in the same way that just where
did that just merely by itself he's not
expecting it he's not seeing it mennies
hit like that that it's it's on you as a
player not to hit somebody who is
defenseless I I would agree with that
you know it's on you on not hitting a
player that's defensive I mean the rule
is there you're supposed to or to to
kind of apply it there's something to
say
like there's you know you I think I saw
Wayne Gretzky get hit once you know at
center ice and and the reason was a lot
of those guys when they would make a
play you you can't just watch your puck
you know and you could clearly see their
the kid is watching his putt now doesn't
mean there's a right to hit that player
but I think it's second there's that I
can't remember what it is it's like
either one second or you know it's you
know a tenth of a second now or you know
a half a second I don't know what the
timing is but you know definitely you
can't hit guys from behind and you can't
hit guys to the head and if a player is
totally defenseless absolutely we got to
protect a players first do you think
somebody's reputation should play into
this yep I think it does I think it does
the league keeps track of all the guys
that keep doing it over and over and
absolutely I'm that I wouldn't see the
reputation as much as if the guys has a
habit of doing it absolutely it does
yeah what's the dirtiest hit you've ever
been on the recipient receiving end of
uh dirtiest hit I've ever been part of
probably
Craig Simpson hit me real hard at center
ice when I wasn't looking kind of like
that we come in the head and I would say
mark 10 or D mark 10 or D I wasn't
listening he hit me so hard that my
stick flew in the stands I got up I
didn't know what this is like pre when
we knew how to handle concussion and I
was kind of out and I was looking for my
sick I couldn't find it
came back to the bench they gave me a
little sniffer and he went back and
played it was crazy nose things so who's
the one who who enforced that action on
your team who's the one who came out and
enforced after something like that hit
no one quick sister there was no one but
we always had Marty McSorley to take
care of us he was always there helping
us on the mark tune or anyone I got him
later which I was very happy yeah and he
was like are you kidding me I think he
couldn't believe that I got him but I
think he got a kick out of it that I got
him back okay I like it I'd like to take
a break come back and talk a little bit
about you
your history with the cup I want my best
cup story that you're able to tell all
right public okay I want to and I want
to go down like some Gretzky and
obviously you played a couple years with
the Penguins yeah so you were around
greatness quite a bit in your career as
being great on your own right Luc
Robitaille is here Doug Marrone of the
Jacksonville Jaguars will also join us
here on this edition of the Rich Eisen
show an hour number two that has a visit
from Ralph Macchio and I will draw a
line between the NBA Finals LeBron James
and Ralph Macchio and Cobra Kai yeah Wow
[Laughter]
so when we say goodbye to you then there
is a Luc Robitaille Ralph Macchio
crossing of paths I'm very proud of
those things here on the Rich Eisen show
back with more in a moment
welcome back Luc Robitaille here as part
of the insider report brought to you by
Honda the official vehicle of the
National Hockey League and with the
spacious Honda Pilot has seating up to
eight you need to hurry in to your local
Honda dealer and check out the Honda
Pilot today Luc Robitaille here I mean
the players that you played with in your
career I mean you could not have been
surrounded by such greatness and again
you retired as the greatest scoring
left-winger in NHL history
you won your Cup in Detroit yep and all
my team was go ahead lay it out for me
here I mean it was we counted the other
day when it's all said and done adding
Pavel debt so there was 10 players that
will be in the Hall of Fame it's amazing
out of 20 is incredible it was like
Nicklaus from Steve Yzerman Dominik
Hasek Brett Hall Shanahan Pavel Datsyuk
Chris Chelios Igor Larionov and I'm
vests off to Federoff yeah I'm missing
another one that was you know it's gonna
be upset at me but anyway Pavel Datsyuk
yeah and when the coach was Scotty
Bowman I mean it was it wasn't it was it
was the pre cap era where they were
allowed to put a team together that was
a you know it was pretty special I mean
we finished first overall and you know
went through the
the entire playoffs I mean it wasn't
easy but we had a great team a couple of
years in Madison Square Garden you're
spending yeah yeah that was fun with
Mark Messier I was pretty special to
play with the new years of the Penguins
big boy yeah no big winner was there one
year because there was a lockout okay
that's a year Mario unfortunately didn't
play he had two bad back but I got to
play I think it was really Yeager's big
year coming out it was he had won the
Cup before but that was the UE he led
the league in scoring Ron Francis was
there was pretty special team too
and then of course the great one yeah in
Los Angeles my idol you know growing up
so it's pretty cool to get to play with
him that was pretty special what was
that like Luke here in Los Angeles
there's really hard for me at first
because you know when I was you know
we're like five or six years apart so
when he was 18 I was 12 13 and you know
watching him you know when you're 12 and
13 you watched someone your idolized him
when he got to when I got to play with
him and he got traded to LA I remember
they put me with him and I think was I
gained two when I was playing with him
and we're coming down a two-on-one and I
want to give him the perfect pass cuz
when Gretzky you know I want to and I'm
as I pass it to him the defense first
stops it and when he comes back to the
bench and he he wasn't doing it
maliciously he just say hey lucky goes
next time just give it to me early he
goes I'll give it back to you don't
worry I'm like he's got a good point you
know so for the next month I think every
single time I touch the puck it was like
I agree now just like the coach came to
me says I'm gonna take he off his line
he goes you're not even trying to make a
play anymore you just keep giving them
but the puck but it was I was really
nervous it took me almost a year to
really start talking with him or
treating him like a like a normal person
on a colleague
yeah I know like it wasn't like that for
me it was like I was very intimidated
around him always where did you grow up
I grew up in Montreal Montreal yeah okay
so then this is your perfect person
asked this question - oh the Marty Marty
McSorley stick yeah that was taken out
of play and that Stanley Cup Finals
against the Montreal Canadiens where
you're now taking on the Canadiens yeah
and the fact that Canada ever since that
has not won a cups
do you think that that was a curse that
was placed on the country as a whole
I don't know affected they took my stick
out of play and that Stanley Cup Finals
I don't know if it was put on the entire
country but but I got stories about that
debt curve I mean I know they measured
it like their trainers came out and
measured some sticks right before the
game between there were two stick racks
right right by their locker room and
that said there was a deal form and and
they told the policemen to look the
other way and they grabbed a bunch at
one of them was mine Marty and Thomas
Sandstrom Alex it make whole tenement
let's let's back up here so before this
Stanley Cup game the one in which the
stick was removed or prior to what
happened is you have a stick rack and
you know you always have two or three
sticks so so what happened someone in
their organization I don't know who came
and grabbed three or four sticks took
him in a room measured them put him back
so they they knew which one was illegal
and the reason I know that is like seven
years later this policeman that used to
work around the locker room was always
really I was always really nice to him
whenever Ellie would come in he'd ask me
for something I'd give him a stick or
something for his kids or grandkids
finally one day he came to me says I
need to apologize to you for something
go really what he goes I was there I go
you were there way go see they told me
to look away and they measured a bunch
of sticks so that's the only reason I
know that will not change the Stanley
Cup final that oh yeah I mean you know
we lost the next two game we lost
actually even that game even though they
score to make it to two we went to
overtime mm-hmm they scored and then the
next two games were big overtime games
in LA we could have won those games I
mean Patrick Roy was really a difference
maker but you know you're up to one with
a couple minutes left you know
definitely you'd rather not be on the
penalty kill then then killing a penalty
but I'm not sure was only that stick I
think you know losing those games in
overtime and Patrick what was the
biggest difference maker well I mean
you're going high-class here but at some
point somebody from the Canadiens
organization told the policeman attorney
I'm not sure I put on the entire country
but I definitely
oh definitely wasn't right of them to do
in there because it's hard to pick out
like an illegal curb it's really hard so
you kind of had to make sure and you
know so but that's the way it goes here
but that the rule was there the rule is
you have to have you stick legal yeah so
the rule was there for us to obey it and
you know if it's part of the rules part
of rule Luc Robitaille here a couple
more minutes in the insider report
brought to you by Honda now you are an
executive okay and say what you've want
you've been part of two Cup wins as an
executive it better is an executive
order player what are you well you never
know what it takes to win a championship
on till you win a championship and so
I'm glad I won as a player because you
you kind of understand what it does for
the team and the trainer because you
know winning a Stanley Cup it's two
months it's like a you know it's like
going out war almost for two months
worth you're just it's very special when
you win as an executive you realize it
influences that many more people yeah I
don't think as a player you realize what
it does for a city and season seat
holders have been supporting and a
franchise for 40 years and so forth and
and so for me was very interesting you
see both sides
that being said to a love that was part
of the organization for the first time
we won the Cup in LA that was pretty
amazing yeah I bet certainly since again
there's those Canadians note that what's
your what's your best cup story that you
can tell in public ah the best cup story
I could tell in public well there's a
lot to probably I think before us you
know there's better stories because now
there's a guardian they really guard it
for me it was like a when I was in
Detroit we you know that they they lent
me that the cup and my family had come
and we just rented that there was no
cars to rent and there was so my wife
had this small car and Ken holida GM
said why don't you take it for the day
and he we didn't know what to put in the
car so my kids and my wife were in the
car so we'll put it on a passenger seat
just put a seat belt around it on the
kids were in the back and we're driving
in andhe trouble going through we just
had an apartment because my family was
still in LA
and so we're driving in and we stop at a
red light and in Detroit people were
going nuts alike but it didn't make
sense was like just this tiny little car
was really it was a Honda but it made it
for like a fun day and then we took it
back home and you know got to enjoy
where kids put popcorn in and watch a
movie it was it was really special Honda
the official car of a Stanley Cup
sitting shotgun in the city that's right
I love it good to see you Luke bro but
sad to say this is a lot of fun dad
you're just down the road right yeah
we're just down the road it was like a
two minute drive here leerin a like I
think it was less than that fantastic
well we're geographically sound we'd
love to have a big fan of yours for also
your skating move get you on the ice
again I think I need some help nine
seven and four-year-olds are already
literally skating rings around me but
that said we also saw video of Brockman
find his own five hole trying to shoot a
tear Matt good to see you look the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience